ready yeah hey guys it's the evident
caitlyn podcast the show that is now
long i knew you were gonna say that
as apparent alright guys so today we are
going to be doing a Q&A with our live
audience that's on twitch right now if
you're listening to this later sorry if
you like the format of this episode and
if you like the idea of interacting with
us live we might do it again let us know
if it's good by getting the view numbers
up so share with your friends so we are
also going to be doing a little game
time
interactive with the audience - can you
tell about that oh yeah so what we're
gonna do at the end after our Q&A is a
lyric game similar to the game we've
played with each other where we read
each other lyrics and try to guess what
the song is what you think would be easy
but it's actually very challenging
especially if your oven so what we're
gonna do is everyone here in the live
stream will submit lyrics and we try to
guess what those are which will be I
think maybe more difficult because like
when I'm choosing ones for you I'm like
oh yeah yeah yeah there's a chance we
could get anything like I don't know any
popular songs right now we're good both
we're going to walk down the day and
we're like Kaitlin what music plays and
clubs these days what's the clubbing
music what is the music of the club it
used to be like Ke$ha Lady Gaga I don't
have no idea that's one of the songs
here I'm not gonna have any idea part of
the fun of going out is like knowing the
song was like dancing along with them
and stuff like that and like my approach
would be incredibly nerdy would do
research Kaitlyn would listen to the
radio musics just talk to it like my
younger cousin and be like what's cool
before we move into the Q&A segment
though we are gonna be doing some news
and the main thing we want to talk about
is the YouTube check marks yeah although
it's it's kind of funny because it was
like a huge thing and now it's not a
thing anymore but I think that that is a
huge thing I think that's like really
big news for those of you who haven't
heard about the YouTube check mark drama
I don't know if it's a big thing to
everyone else but as a content creator
wouldn't you reach a hundred thousand
subscribers you can apply to get a check
mark and that like to us was just a
really nice pat on the back from YouTube
saying like you get this special little
thing worth a check mark you are worth a
check mark and I kind of liked that
YouTube had it such a simple system of
like you reach 100k you prove that you
own that channel you get a check mark
because you are you and that's cool and
other platforms like Twitter you need to
be newsworthy you need to like have
articles you need to like show that
you're in danger of getting impersonated
if on Instagram you wanted to get
verified I think it's the same thing you
need to like link to articles from
reputable sources showing that you're
important that basically means legacy
media like TV and big articles news
platforms yeah by the way legacy instead
of like what's like there's new media I
used to call it like old media legacy
media and I like fancy I know I stole it
it was the creator unknown yeah so yeah
that's the verification on all the other
platforms and like I think it's very
confusing
and I think that it is very subjective
where YouTube's was very straightforward
anyways YouTube saw those other
platforms doing it in that way and
YouTube's like oh maybe we need to like
change it to like maybe the same thing I
mean the same thing so YouTube was
capitulating basically and going to the
going the route of other platforms
instead of just keeping it very simple
but the sucky thing was that meant that
a lot of people and so if we built like
with
larger channels and iams of subscribers
subscribers were losing their check mark
so everybody freaked out which and like
we were sad to my mom was visiting and
we were like oh my god really like go
check mark and she was like what I never
noticed the check mark what's a check
mark you know but like it's like a big
deal but I think the cool thing is you
know there's a lot of people like
speaking out about it and YouTube like
went back on their change yeah and and
was like you know we missed the mark
yeah we missed the mark we're gonna go
back to how things were
and I think yeah like you're saying
that's the crazy part because usually
YouTube like they'll push out a change
people are upset and that's the way it
is but I think one reason why they were
able to go back on it is because this
change was coming from YouTube and it
was just about YouTube yeah you know it
was there is no pressure from like big
companies or stakeholders or traditional
media or like a standing them supervisor
but there's no external factor pushing
YouTube in this direction YouTube's like
we're just gonna do that and everyone's
like no okay we won't do that yeah but
it is it is kind of exciting that that
YouTube listened and they change and I
think that's the bigger more important
news than just the Dom about the check
mark so hopefully they keep that up
because we have a lot of opinions in
other news we are starting another
channel we are it's not thing
drastically different from stuff we've
already done but a lot of you guys
especially here on Twitch know that we
have a gaming channel we're starting
another gaming channel for all of the
uncut streams and I know we just
announced recently that we're putting
the uncut streams on our main gaming
channel but glad some feedback that
that's very confusing and they're hard
to find so there's gonna be another
gaming channel I know it seems silly but
I think it makes the most sense well our
general philosophy is like we want
people to sign up for what they want
Ivan and Kahlan that's fairly
consistently like us making things in
our garage and having fun effing and
Kaelyn gaming our edited highlights and
if all of a sudden we started putting
editing hi edited highlights and
uncut full streams you would either be
getting double what you want which would
be kind of good or you would be getting
one thing you want and one thing you
don't want yeah it is kind of a
different auditory so we gonna be doing
that we haven't actually said it
anywhere this is the first time we're
mentioning it but guys like so it's
called evident Kaitlyn gaming uncut
because if you find it and subscribe
right now you're gonna get you're gonna
get five notifications of the day of
like catch up on our I don't even know
how many 115 115 livestream 115 live
streams
yeah so we're will be working on that
but if you want to sub just kidding you
can do that just be prepared for ordered
another modem and I upgraded our wire
our our our internet speed so I could
like alka load more because we're just
uploading so much for our 5 channels now
yeah it's a lot you know evident Kaitlyn
- we'll probably still stay somewhat
dormant until we figure it out but 5
channels yeah ok so before we move on to
the live stream let's take a little bit
of a break you mean to the Q&A before we
move on to the Q&A let's let's take a
little bit of a break to say hi to chat
and interact with people and now time
for the Q&A
wait it stopped and now time for the Q&A
that was mighty so fancy my pinky lip I
know we don't get to use that music very
often you know what QA I just want to
use the soundboard all the time good
okay so guys hit us with those cues and
we have all of the A's for you yeah we
got your eggs right here
coming in hot yeah let's see oh man oh
you're scrolling and I can't see
anything what do you guys enjoy art made
by fans even if it's not art of you guys
or your content we love fan art yeah you
love we're fans of art in general we
actually do have a discord which we
haven't publicized too much and on the
disc art gourd there's a whole channel
for art showcase so you can share your
art with us and everyone in the discord
will put a link to it and the notes for
this episode um Monday Monday podcast
release still yes I'm still gonna come
out Monday just cuz like you know we got
to take a little time to edit and stuff
what's your favorite song that's like oh
such an impossible question cuz there's
a song for each thing okay let me guess
let me guess yours Queen Bohemian
Rhapsody you know what's weird what's
that cuz I was thinking like it's really
hard to pick a favorite song but what's
like the song I go back to singing the
most Queen Bohemian Rhapsody I was like
when I read that in my in my head I was
like mama okay so what'd be my favorite
song it's up there it's up there why do
I like sing the most besides Disney
songs cuz do Disney songs even really
count I think your favorite song could
be a Disney song you're right yeah okay
um your favorite song I mean I'm mostly
going based off like things that get
stuck in your head that you sing a lot
but that doesn't necessarily mean
they're your favorite cuz some song is
just like gets stuck in your head and I
almost like much no no no got stuck in
my head
oh the funny thing is like how you can
say just a small part of something and
that triggers it being in your head like
[Laughter]
there's like head smash your headphones
off that's what you got to do so what
kind of house renault projects are you
guys planning on doing we have so so our
house we've done a lot of the like super
necessary like slightly more ambitious
projects and some of them we had done
before we even started the channel so I
think most of the things we have left on
this house are a little bit more
cosmetic like what I'm just laughing for
somebody so I think like when we have
coming up is we're gonna do like the
next part of our guest room makeover I
guess I kind of started when we did
Murphy beds but we're gonna be doing
some stuff there we want to redo some
stuff in our office but it's like light
DIY and kind of more cosmetic things
like huge I think the big thing for us
is eventually we know we're gonna move
out of this house yeah we're already
starting to grow out of it
we've already improved enough that is
kind of like even better than what we
can sell it for you know so it's like at
this point we'll just be sinking money
into the house without really seeing the
financial benefit of it and stuff for
like our next house yeah but also we've
been expanding what we need from a house
now we need like an office and a
streaming room because room that we're
in right now this is like a 13 by 13
foot room max and we have two two-person
desks in it yes it's a lot so you know
as we continue to expand evident Caitlin
the scope of what we need in our next
house keeps on expanding so I kind of
want to get to equilibrium get to like a
steady state before we get any like I
don't know before we decide that we need
this house and then later on we need to
move again I just I just want to want to
move like maybe one more time
we move so much chill for a little bit
maybe it's cuz we move so much when we
were younger we're like let's just
minimize the moving now I also think
that we moved into this house before we
were married we did before we we lived
together in an apartment for a year and
then we moved into our house together
and this has been an amazing first house
yeah but for the next house I think that
we might even hang on to this house for
just a little bit because we know this
house in this area that we're in sells
pretty fast get the other house and like
really renovated and document it so if
you guys like home improvement projects
stick around for the next one to five
years one to five years and at some
point in the future you're gonna get a
whole bunch of renovation content
because we really want to like tackle it
and we want to like do all of the things
we've learned like make sure the doors
are hung properly
you know like scrape the ceilings the
popcorn off you know we want like we
want to do all of that stuff somebody
somebody called us out on our popcorn
walls there was like a fairly easy way
that isn't horribly messy extremely
dusty and just horrible we probably
would do it but yeah it's so disruptive
okay question from Quebec I'm curious
how you two came to this decision to
have such sanitized language on your
channel and what factored into that it's
like not cursing and stuff yeah so I
think a big part of it is we we try to
imagine like who might be watching our
videos and in the beginning it was like
I mean we don't curse like a ton in real
life anyway we curse a little bit in
real life but not not enough that it
would be like hard to not do it for the
period of a video so we're like let's
just not just in case and then as we
started making more and more videos we
just got so many messages from people
who are like I watch this with my kids
my 8 year old loves your channel and
it's like okay we like really do want to
try to keep the language clean knowing
that people watch our videos with their
kids because we don't want people to
feel like all of a sudden they can't do
that anymore you know also we don't
curse that much if I get like if we get
injured or if like premiers crashing or
if it's just been one of those days yes
you just gotta go for it in the Attic
video where we were doing our attic
organization and you fell through the
ceiling I I cursed mine of course I
still bleeped it but like there was just
as much surprise about me cursing then
there was about you I think the funny
thing is like after we after we shut off
the cameras and I was just sitting there
on the edge with my feet dangling into
the office looking down looking this bug
down like what we had to deal with we
like really just said some bad words for
a period of time let them all out let
them fall through the hole in the
ceiling and then we went downstairs and
cleaned it all up oh you know the one
regret like well one regret is obviously
falling through the ceiling I wish I
hadn't have done that but one regret
that we had is we didn't take a video
and pictures of my feet hanging through
honestly like just kind of in shock and
worried and I was like worried about you
being hurt and we wanted to get you up
as soon as we could we could have like
staged it afterwards and we haven't been
topper youtubers we would have gotten
the thumbnail with my feet dangling
through and use that as the thumbnail I
know we're terrible alright do you have
an Instagram account for the supervisor
no but that would be kind of cute but at
the same time oh there's like we're in
so many different places were on so many
different social media platforms and I
feel like we're doing I feel like we're
not doing the best job at all of them
cuz we have so many yeah like we have we
have a subreddit if you guys want to
check it out it's called our slash
evident Elin and we didn't post our
videos no I go there once a week and I
check in and I like replied some
comments and stuff but
we want to be everywhere because we know
that everyone has a favorite platform
then she's got to have a Twitter she's
got to have a subreddit but I think we
could post more pictures of the
supervisor oh I'd be down for that on
evident Kaitlyn yes because she is
fabulous she always looks fabulous yeah
especially with the new camera that we
have but yeah well now she shows up
shows up how do you not have a make fall
make fall maybe that's something coming
up someone in the future why don't we
start renovating other youtubers houses
um I mean that could be cool there's a
lot of logistics involved and also we're
not professionals at renovating so it's
kind of limited and like like we don't
mind doing stuff to our house cuz if it
breaks we can fix it later but we don't
want to we want to want to do anything
that's maybe like potentially shoddy
work and then leave and we can't go back
and fix it if it's in our house we can
just like oh we'll fix that
wall so there's there's a factor of time
to all of this because we're trying to
balance a certain output that we want to
keep up you know like right now we're in
the middle of a buffer week which is
incredibly painful for us too I know
that like we want to make more videos
for you guys for a lot of different
reasons it's it's great to not post a
video because we can get ahead and it
sucks to not post a video because we
really want to post videos all the time
yeah and and traveling coordinating
figuring out like if we're gonna be
renovating someone's house the video
goes on our channel are we gonna do a
video for theirs and if we're filming a
video for us and for the collaborators
channel we're filming two videos instead
of just filming and editing one it just
takes more time yeah and with all the
things we've got going on we're like you
know last year was the year of
collaborations and events and this year
is the year of trying to get a better
balance trying to get a better balance
we've started we've started three
channels this year the podcast the
gaming and now
hi I'm gaming uncut yeah do we use any
software to post to our platforms or any
automation no every single thing we
write everything we do everything all by
ourselves yeah it's it's kind of good
that way because a lot of automation
software doesn't perfectly transition
between Instagram and Twitter so a lot
of people post on Instagram and they
copy that caption to Twitter but you
know the the caption gets truncated you
know what I mean
so we manually write it for Instagram
and Twitter and on Twitter we shortened
it so that the same intent is conveyed
even in less words but it usually gets
extra posts too because like we'll just
post random funny stuff everything is so
much more casual I I've really been
enjoying Instagram yeah it's like it has
to be a pretty picture it has to be like
something worth posting caption yeah see
just Caitlyn design all them I do I get
to use my old graphic design skills it's
really fun it's really cool seeing her
design them also because she gathers the
whole inspiration board she has like a
whole suite of like ideas and colors and
all sorts of like patterns and stuff
like that and then she starts with one
concept and another and another another
another so she has like nine concepts
and then she takes one concept that she
thinks is promising and then there's
four iterations of that but even this
big fail make fail make fail you went
through so many different types of like
do we stack them do we overlap them are
they solid do they fade in a gradient
you know and and it took you like
there's a lot of work that goes into
this I'm impressed
let's see do you ever find yourself
getting burnt out on particular project
types I wouldn't say we really get burnt
out on particular project types but I
think that's because on our channel
we've always tried to like we purposely
really try to mix it up a bunch so that
is why we bounce around a lot in one day
it'll be
resin then it'll be something but then
it'll be a home project then it'll be
like an art related thing and I think
that helps prevent us from getting burnt
out I thought of something I got burnt
out on one there is a period we were
doing a whole bunch of projects using
large cheap goods right oh it was it was
the dang Murphy beds yes and the laundry
room oh yeah and I was like horsie good
for a period of time I just don't want
to do anymore sheet goods because like
we bought like eight four by eight
sheets of plywood and brought them right
at home on our small car and I just
remember like struggling with so many
giant sheets of plywood trying to get
them into our garage the garage makeover
so there was no room we didn't film it
also cause like if you don't like
there's a lot of safety concerns we
didn't want to publish this but I we
made a roof rack for our car with these
like suction pads and everything and
this aluminum and like like two by fours
and everything it worked okay but I
certainly wouldn't recommend it
especially if you can't just drive on
side roads yeah because like on top of a
car sheets of plywood unless you have
like also some sort of a wind catch or
wind deflector you know that's that's a
surface area and that wind can really
just like put so much force on those
sheets and everything so that's that's
scary but we don't want to put it on the
Internet yeah because people may not be
as safe as us when they use it so do you
guys have more by verse DIY videos
coming up yes yes oh my gosh we are so
excited
we've already bought it we have it it's
like in the room yeah because we're not
gonna do that until the end of the video
when we compare guys it's hilarious yeah
it's kind of like it's much more silly
you know the light was very practical
yeah this is something it's still a
thing that you can buy and that one
might DIY but it's a different it's a
different set of skills it's not what
working and it's very silly so I don't
know if it's gonna be the next one or if
we'll do another kind of like slightly
more practice
go on first I think we should definitely
do a practical one first I think that we
need to sell anyone for later because
when you're starting series and when
you're starting things you need to set
up a certain precedent of how things are
gonna go set expectations and
expectation we want to have is we it's
gonna be the same us we're gonna be
still doing practical thing this but
also the Triforce Eri
really opens up for some amazing video
possibilities like things a few more
things to buy in mine too so we have a
question of the many things you do which
one makes your heart beat the fastest
live-streaming
yeah live-streaming is the very first
few times we live streamed I was a
little bit nervous I did kind of get a
little yeah honestly I get a little
nervous when like when we do something
drastically different so like I got a
little nervous before this we've never
done like a live podcast nervous I was
like oh man what it was terrible but
like after a hundred and fifteen live
streams on Twitch my heart race doesn't
raise it all my you know it's like I
don't like it nervous about it at all
anymore just doing games just doing
games just doing our usual routine of
things but yet new things do get us a
little nervous but I would say
live-streaming gets us very excited so
like heart racing in in that regard too
it's fine it's like fun hanging out life
on avenue caitlin - have you thought
about making cooking videos we have
considered it i think um the thing is
we've also considered doing it on the
main channel but like more experimental
cooking videos where it's kind of like
science adjacent type stuff because then
it would kind of fit with the with the
other science adjacent videos like the
first one we did was can epoxy cook an
egg yeah that was I think before we had
the science adjacent theme song but
that's cuz we felt that we could do like
anything with resin we can do fun to do
something that like is a little bit more
sciency like what if we tried to make
taffy or something you know where it's
like there's chemical reactions you have
to get it to the right temperature I
think that can be kind of fun but yeah I
don't know where that video would go
like it would be second Channel or
something but also I think that this is
the the main focus that we have right
now just for our life we need to get
ahead enough on videos that we can relax
and I think that means like two videos
ahead yeah and then we can start to
relax because like when we're when we're
working the week of its it's not good
yeah we we still enjoy our life we still
enjoy our days we like what we're doing
but personally mentally it's stressful
when you're dealing with things like
sponsors sponsors are like resin can
take a really long time to dry it if it
messes up you have to start over you
lost a day I mean like a week lead is
minimum isn't minimum and maybe if we
have to then we can't change builds are
relaxing if we ever get to three I think
that's when we can start experimenting
again yeah with like more experimental
videos or maybe even Katelyn - yeah so
we really are trying to like get our
lives and keep our like lives with a
high priority I'm not sure if that makes
sense but it's like we we want to ensure
that we don't burn out for you guys and
for us you know yeah I mean I think that
everyone wants more videos we want more
videos but if it comes at the cost of
you know yeah it's a negative impacts on
us I think that's something that
everyone agrees like don't don't do that
cuz there's not too much more room to
give right now like we don't have
weekends we don't like we work in the
evenings and that's our choice yeah
that's our choice it's so that we can do
everything that we are doing but there's
right now not really extra room to give
to additional additional channels I mean
even though we just started another but
you know what I mean that one doesn't
take more work but also it's like every
time we try new thing we push ourselves
we learn we expand so it's good we want
to do that but we just need to open up a
little bit of space in our life so that
we can do that yeah and I think
hopefully once we get the gaming channel
to like a more legit number I'm not sure
what that means I'm not sure what that
will do but I think that once gaming
channel is recognized more as part of
identity we might be able to relax and
explore new things potentially that's
Jim who knows because then our eggs will
be in more different baskets and
there'll be more balance
and I'm like there won't be as much
pressure on Evan and Caitlin because
that's we make a cooking video and it
flops it's like the evidence main
channel is like that's our job
everything else we do our dislike but
the gaming channel loses money the
podcast essentially loses money I mean
the gaming channel we pay editors so we
actually lose money yeah the podcast
success just takes a lot of time and we
don't really make much it essentially
loses money so they're like pet projects
yeah I think their investments in our
long-term happiness something figure it
out okay so how do you guys like being
full-time youtubers I like that was
never a goal of ours that was never
something that we wanted to do growing
up but I think that's also because that
wasn't an option
you know and now that we're here I think
it is such a good fit for the two of us
personally we both like making stuff we
want our time to like result in
something especially if it's like
potentially tangible or long-lasting or
like non ethereal you know make
something that like stands the test of
time a little bit and then both of us
also like sharing it with the broader
world and in the like we both get a lot
of happiness and joy from that and if
being a youtuber was an option if that
had been a possibility when we were
younger we might have been drawn to this
yeah we might I mean we both like would
make stuff and post it on the Internet
yeah but that was like before anyone was
really doing that yeah like doing that
as a Johnny NARS and blogs and oh yeah
we both had blogs oh yeah even more like
smaller communities yes I won't mention
the nikah thing because you might be
able to find us but um I think that that
it is a very good fit for the two of us
we do multiple times a week be like wow
I'm really happy with our life and the
life that we've like created for
ourselves so
how do you like being full-time
youtubers it's working out well for us
yeah it's fine but it's not for
everybody
I definitely say it's not for everybody
yeah it's it's I mean it's like any
small business where it's a lot of work
I think one of the potentially more
stressful things about it and this kind
of relates to a question I saw about
like what's our retirement plan like
YouTube retirement plan just this but
but it's kind of like there is no
retirement plan yeah you know what I
mean not not that like we're gonna work
until we're a hundred but in that like
there's I just know guys other crazy
thought but okay
just like there's the there's not people
of retirement age that started YouTube
careers when they were you know of
working age and have worked to their
entire lives till retirement and are
still youtubers like that that hasn't
happened this hasn't been a job for long
enough so there's not like a set path or
a common path people do say that
everyone's just kind of figuring it out
or burning out before they go yeah I had
was like man like in 50 years are you
like people are gonna be able to go back
and watch all of our hundreds of videos
and just watch us reverse age or if they
like start at the beginning and watch
them all in order
they're just gonna be able to like watch
us age slowly over time that's weird
already been on you know we've had the
channel for two years maybe we've
already aged my hair was a lot lighter
when we started there's that I had less
of a beard yeah you had less of a beard
Ruby Rhodes grow my beard has like grown
I accidentally chopped off and then it
grew again let's see how do we come up
with our DIY ideas
oh man I mean there's a lot of different
things sometimes it's like something we
need you know around the house and then
we'll try to think of a way to make it
interesting or unique sometimes it's
just like a process that seems fun to
try so a lot of the the more like art
related ones like the acrylic pores or
when we first tried resin art or even
like doing the Bob Ross
it just seemed like it'd be fun it's not
that we like needed a Bob Ross painting
or like needed an acrylic poor it just
seemed like it would be fun to try so a
lot of it comes from that every now and
then an idea will come from like the
fact that we just think it would be
hilarious and usually those videos don't
do as well because they're not there's
nothing like practical about them so
that's like the like the zombie weapon
video we just really wanted to destroy
fruit and vegetables with the zombie
weapon and or like the propane cannon I
guess it's like the weapons so a lot of
times we think that those would just be
really fun to do mmm or like funny to do
yeah I think that for our projects in
general we want to have a few different
things one we want the project to result
in a fun video mm-hmm because if it's if
it's just something so basic or
something that like there isn't much
going for it then I just don't think
it'll make a fun video and I think
though sometimes we do stuff that's like
DIY stuff that we don't put on the
channel like we just made a frame around
our green screen behind us that has like
lights all around it but it was just
real quick and basic and we're like we
won't make a video on it not I mean if
we had all the time in the world we
would but it's like we got a prioritize
but also I'm just not sure what that
video would be like we made a box we
stuck lights in it here it is I bet I
bet we could if we got so many things
were more excited yeah you know yeah
that's true too okay so we got a
question why is the live stream here on
Twitch and not on YouTube it's mixed
it's a mixed thing one if we did our
live stream on our on our YouTube main
channel the questions would be coming in
so fast it's there's obviously a little
bit stressful overwhelming overwhelming
yeah and I think they would need to
almost have someone here next to us
looking at all the chaps collating
questions and then reading them to us
would need like a third person to
facilitate that why isn't it on the
YouTube podcast Channel
I think that YouTube is trying to do so
many things all once that does so many
of them but one thing that's interesting
this twitch is built up from like the
whole infrastructure is built around
live streaming so we have mods that have
commands there's nightbot that's in here
that can do things it integrates with
like third-party accessories there's um
like a checklist so that like you know
wall we're live streaming right now I
see that we have three no we have four
new subscribers and one person shared
and that's all I collected on the side
through a third-party plug-in via an API
and it's just things are so much more
open and developed I think that YouTube
is catching up I think that they are
starting to add more and more features
on YouTube that twitch already enjoys
but as of right now it's just a better
fit for us and what we want to do in
general see how do you deal with the
stigma still attached to being youtubers
or streamers when dealing with average
people who don't get it um I guess like
we when we were first starting out and
we were like telling our friends and
family that we were quitting our jobs to
do YouTube
we definitely got some funny looks I
mean a lot of family members like our
immediate family was pretty supportive
you know some like more distant family
members we're kind of like mmm but just
like I mean we don't really tell people
often what we do I mean we work here by
ourselves like just eat each other we
don't go into an office we we just like
don't often talk to strangers you know
so it doesn't what we do doesn't really
come up with people who aren't friends
or family so we're not really ever in a
position to have to like explain
ourselves now occasionally we do have
like let's say someone comes to the
house because we need like a leak fixed
or something like that and every now and
then people are like curious because
it's a workday and
both here and we're in our pajamas and
we got all this crazy stuff in our house
we're just where's we just are an
advertising agency we've said things
depending on like what part of the house
they saw if they saw the garage and see
all the tools we say like oh we make
things if they see like well I don't
know what we've I don't I don't think
we've had to like it when we're out and
about and like someone might ask like
what we do I kind of didn't really say
think about it most of our income comes
from sponsors so it's kind of like
advertising like amateur brands to
create sometimes I'll say like we like
create content oh yeah but I don't often
use the word but more and more people
understand you know the the career that
is being a youtuber it's becoming more
known and I don't think that there's as
much of a stigma around it as much it's
just like it can be a long conversation
and depending if we want to have that
long conversation or not it's like if
there are a family or a friend of you
know of course we'll tell them and we'll
explain like how monetization works and
how he like you know all of the back
ends and the nuances that people are
usually curious about but if I just want
to give like a one-word answer or an
advertising agency people understand
that they don't ask follow-up questions
and they're like cool you know we could
just make anything up though we're
secret agents
well that might they might ask questions
if you if you have to make a boring job
accountant we're at Countians nothing
against accountants I could say I'm an
engineer because you do graphic art for
evident Caitlin and I do engineer for
Evan in case that doesn't explain like
the giant green screen and all the tools
that are in our house and fun all right
so what are our favorite life hacks or
upgrades Oh recently the most recent
life hack was filling holes like if
you're trying to screw into wood you can
like fill it with wood putty and a
toothpick I know what wood glue in a
toothpick
yeah
a lot of people said that like dowels
dowels or like golf teams Oh golf yeah
no I feel like oh man I feel like there
was one recently oh really
this is actually really good yeah you
know we should make a list I don't know
if this is super widely put like life
hack this is something we did back in
our blogging days before the channel and
I didn't think of it until so one of our
other friends who also has a YouTube
channel
April Wilkerson was visiting and and we
also got a lot of questions about about
these on the art ledge video but she was
like oh I like that art that's really
cool and it's this like really really
big like probably I don't know three and
a half feet by like five and a half feet
art pieces we have two of them in our
house that have like abstract paintings
on them and the paintings I did one and
Evan did the other but the hack is that
the art is actually like these giant
IKEA has these really giant prints and I
think they're like $59 and that's way
cheaper than you could buy a canvas that
big and that's way cheaper than you
could buy a frame that big especially
trying to buy those together that would
be hundreds of dollars to get a canvas
and frame that big it's my life hack if
you want really large-scale
art you go to Ikea get one of those $59
prints and then you paint it yourself
and it can be super abstract like it
doesn't have to you don't have to have
like painting skills to do like a you
know Bob Ross mard
but that's my life hack that's a good
life I was actually thinking like should
we do a video on that I think about it I
want to do like a series of life hack
videos one life axes are actually life
hacks like that like we get to do a
project that is kind of a life hack and
that's a full project we could do a
progeny do of like a whole bunch of
small life hacks that are actually life
hacks that actually work and well like
test them and say these are good and
then we can do one where we just like
try bad life hacks and make fun of them
I mean everyone's done that but I want
to do it - I still sounds really good ok
so let's take a really quick break
and and check with chat break the
podcast back in the podcast mode Caitlin
what is your all-time favorite video
game I know that's a really hard
question well there's like the nostalgia
mm-hmm favorites and then there's like
the more current favorites and also it's
like there's there's another aspect of
this too is it the game that you've
played the most and that you go back to
the most like you have the most hours in
or is it the game that has like the
fondest spot in your heart okay so I'm
gonna say like I'm combining two games
but they're very similar for for like
nostalgia games mm-hmm its ocarina of
time and majora's mask like those two
zelda games in 64 are like very high up
there in my nostalgia games current
favorite it's Mike I agree I think my
current all-time favourite game is
minecraft because it's so exciting
because I love it and it just like more
solo games I do have some other
favorites from like a few years ago like
I really like limbo and I really like
inside again those are the Last of Us Oh
in The Last of Us Oh Last of Us - coming
out next year I know I know so excited
about that there's a lot of games I
think like both of us can agree our
current favorite is minecraft also
because looking into the future I just I
just get so excited it's exciting
because it like feels like you can just
play forever
you can play forever also it's like once
we're done on the switch like we are
gonna like take our time we are gonna
play it on the switch we're gonna
explore the overworld then we're gonna
play more and neither then we're gonna
go to the end and we're gonna explore
everything do everything on the switch
and then we're gonna go to Java and then
do it again and then we'll probably
install mods and do it again you know I
think we might have different seasons
like we're in season 1 and then we're
gonna have season 2 then season 3 so
we're gonna have like minecraft seasons
and I think that'll be kind of a really
fun thing to do ya know
but my my nostalgia I'm not sure if I
can narrow it down to a
it might be Total Annihilation but I
think my soldier game is actually
real-time strategy games in general cuz
me and my brother played them so much we
would take turns would play against each
other they would play together against
computers play together against online
opponents and real-time strategy games
are just amazing
and I just love them yes um so I am I'm
scrolling we got a lot of chats when we
when we took a break if you couldn't
have your cat as your supervisor what
animal would you have okay make sure
she's not in here so she doesn't hear us
um what animal would we have as our
supervisor I don't know we could have
any other animal that's like it's kind
of like if if you didn't have your right
arm
what would you replace it with well like
a robot I know okay a robot cat no you
can't snuggle that mm I don't cuz I
think like no no I really like I like
all animals in general okay yes I like
cats and dogs but I think that like just
for our life small dogs but dogs are
harder to take care of dogs are so much
than I'm traveling co.labs talking about
would be like more hard than a dog I'm
like what if we had like a baby tiger
that was always a baby well okay if
you're living in Fantasyland then that
would be a pretty easy answer okay again
would it be a tiger a leopard a puma a
Jaguar actually it would be a cheetah
would be a cheetah why why because one
cheetahs meow okay they have like a meow
is it like a meow meow or is it oh wow
okay yeah they and also they are they
they have social anxiety they give
cheetahs like like therapy dogs uh-huh
and I just feel like it would just warm
my heart to like have a socially anxious
cheetah and make them not anxious
anymore
just like expose them to the world
no no no just protect them in a bubble
oh that's another thing
what's to do okay is that is I think
might be about time for the game the
game okay cool so oh yeah music guys it
is game time alrighty so just in case
you missed it earlier on um what we're
gonna do for the game is you guys will
submit lyrics to us and we will read
them out loud and try to guess the song
it's very similar to a game we've played
with each other but when we played it I
could choose songs that I'm like I'm
pretty sure you at least have a chance
at knowing and you choose songs that you
were pretty sure I'd at least have a
chance of knowing so this might be very
terrible but I figured we can try it out
yeah so guys go ahead and submit lyrics
of a song and then we're gonna guess
yeah gonna have to wait for the same the
same person okay
Kailyn okay are we really gonna start
with that one never gonna give you up no
that's out of the way I want it I got it
oh yeah you have to highlight it I want
it I got it I got it
you like my hair gee thanks just bought
it oh gosh oh gosh you know what this is
not why don't you guys should like copy
and paste them and then look them up to
know if we got it right are we just
gonna be guessing and like have no idea
I want it I got it I want it I got it
you like my hair gee thanks just bought
it you like my hair do you think it's
too body
Oh someone just asked like sorry to
river it back into Q&A but someone just
asked how my tiny computers do okay I'll
look that one up and you can take the
next one
yeah and guys from the the lyrics mr.
Nicolas has a command
so type lyrics followed by the lyrics
lyrics once yeah I can't find it and my
computer's I'm just typing no here it is
I want it I got it I want it I got it
you like my hair gee thanks just bought
it am i right oh it's a popular artist
Oh ariana grande oh seven rings I don't
know what that's all right let's try one
more that was a complete fail at dawn
Jake all I can do is read a book to stay
awake and it rips my life away I know a
great escape you know this one yeah you
don't know this all I can do is read a
book stay awake and it rips my heart
away okay what is it you know I don't
know it I don't know this what if I
start singing the beginning okay go for
it all I can do is read a book read a no
actually I don't know the name I don't
know the artist I got the song in
reference to the seven rings it's what
some clubs now told yeah if it's in
clubs right now yeah if some I mean I
know we know that all I can do we know
that one we got the song I think that
still counts okay okay do you undo
another one since I was yeah
I don't believe I don't believe it you
left in peace left me and pieces too
hard to breathe I'm on my knees right
now clubs right now backbeat okay I
going okay the word was on the street
that the fire in your heart is out I'm
sure you've heard it all before but you
never really had a doubt I don't believe
that anyone feels the way I do about you
know oh oh yeah oh yeah yeah I know this
one yeah I know it I know it I totally
know I'm just trying to get the tune in
my head I don't believe that anybody
feels the way I do about you now but the
fire in your heart is out I'm sure
you've heard it all before but you never
yes so by its song by guessing songs we
really mean slightly singing it and
maybe knowing the artist I'm sure our
viewer of your account just like we
should join the twitch sings competition
oh I mean did you guys hear how
harmonious the duo was oh it's not okay
let's see
Oh Oh ASA oasis yeah man we're even bad
at stuff that was out when we were
younger Wonderwall yes Wonderwall that's
totally yes yeah yeah yeah yeah I like
scrolling through some of these and I'm
like I'm not like stop me now cuz I'm
having such a good time okay I won't
stop you
Thanks I just wanted to let you know do
you know what that is
yeah I think so okay state your guess I
think it's Queen you like we don't stop
me now I'm having such a good time I'm
having a ball but I like I don't know
it's such a short line yeah it's like I
feel like it could be from other songs
but I'm gonna say that one's Queen don't
stop yeah okay I got it we got a new one
submitted rocking rocking and rolling
down the beach I'm strolling but the
seagulls poke at my head not fun
I said seagulls stop it now talk about
seagulls poke in your head
that sounds like what happen in clubs I
don't know man yeah we're really bad at
this okay and these are even like long
lyrics where I feel like we should we
should get him yeah watch out my outfits
ridiculous in the club look and so
conspicuous do you know what yeah I'm
not getting any of em I mean I can worry
Angela I think you like in the past
games Yuval took it taking pity on me
and I chosen like ones that you know
that deep down I know in like archival
memory yeah in the club looking so
conspicuous oh yeah oh it's cool
oh yeah I don't know what the song is
wait if I'd like to think of it long
enough I could I could get there the
rest yeah I don't even want to guess do
this can expose how little I know I
think if we can like just get the tune
it counts or something okay
Oh God Jesus on my necklace us us us I
know this one
you know this one 50 cent no no no it's
a female Lady gaga no I mean you're
pretty close I had mentioned her earlier
Ariana Grande no got Jesus on my neck
yeah see you guys see we know like that
genre of club music oh uh sure yeah sure
okay or Ludacris oh let's see broken
this fragile thing now and I can't I
can't pick up the pieces and I've thrown
my words all around but I can't I can't
give you a reason that sounds like
something lyrics to stuff I would have
listened to in high school it sounds
like something that would be like emo
Kaitlyn went through an emo phase I'm
still you know echo yeah there's an emo
echo go back and like listen this stuff
like especially if you're doing
something in the garage and I can just
like play it that's like so that's like
I Fall Out Boy like I'm somewhat
familiar with but you kind of like go
down like certain rabbit holes where I'm
like I don't understand yeah I didn't
really listen to very much well that way
yeah like what was that like the to that
white that white guy that wrapped or
something like that
no I'm high school high school yeah like
there's like this emo then there's like
this white guy an emo white guy that
rapped I think so
you showed me like this the song like
this album on smells like
I don't remember that I mean there's a
lot of emo stuff I have no idea what
those lyrics are do you know no oh hey
Kalin
let's get down to business to defeat the
hotdoggers
when I asked for sons that's a great one
Disney I think we'll be better at Disney
songs yes I mean if you send Disney ones
like we'll just get it because that's
cheating that's that's called throwing
me a bone
she was a boy she was a girl can I make
it any more obvious skater boy Avril
Lavigne thank you for playing into my
high school music choices I got those so
if someone submitted should I hang my
head low should I bite my tongue or
should I have March with every stranger
from Twitter to get stuff done
that's got to be reason cuz it mentions
twitter twitter I know but like I
thought you're gonna say do my ears hang
low
we are exhibition cuz like technically
those are lyrics blew up a cop oh thank
you that's awesome
Bango ding thank you so much thank you
I've never seen the cuff blow up that
much I know that might be like the
biggest like single chunk of bits we've
ever gotten
yeah I don't know how to scroll with
your mouse oh my gosh I have rolls
birthday today how old is she turning
older than us Oh could you clicked in on
the this roll thing that I roll I don't
know what is it you know it too I think
qapla bottom jeans boots with the fur
with the
okay I like when people write out the
words with with things that are
emphasized because it helps me imagine
them I don't ever want to feel like I
did that day but take me to the place I
love give you all the way I'm supposed
to know that I think I know it I just I
just appreciate the emphasis ah but I
think I know it was it Red Hot Chili
Peppers
right can you sing it no totally honest
I feel like I feel like that is it
though hold on I just got it
I just got it like just for herself this
is from me Yeah right not to under the
bridge okay I know one okay head
shoulders knees and toes head shoulders
well actually I don't know I'm not a
real fan I'm a big fan of little road
head shoulders knees and toes oh my gosh
okay um find light in the beautiful sea
I choose to be happy you and I were like
diamonds in the sky trying to you're a
shooting star I see a vision of ecstasy
when you hold me I'm alive we're like
diamonds in the sky shine bright like a
diamond
yeah I needed to get there a little bit
but I see ah oh there's a secret SIA
version SIA
saying and had like different like cuz
see a really interesting artist in
general we went and saw her concert
which was amazing but also she writes so
many of the songs that other people sing
yeah and she kind of demos it there's
this like there's a person that she
plays piano with her like they played
the piano she sings the lyrics and it's
so interesting to hear her original
version of
so many songs that like some sure sure
will like sing it in the completely
different way yeah I'm like how she
wrote it and initially kind of like
pitched feel of the song and so I'm just
like it's like so much it's like such a
different message it's crazy yeah it's
super interesting it's understand that
the lyrics are slowly forming like as we
exposed the very narrow range of music
and genre and like time period like the
lyrics are starting to shift more in
line with what we know oh man oh my gosh
some of these I just have I just have no
idea but I have to read it do you know
this by the way how much is the fish how
much is the fish yee-ha sunshine in the
air do you know what you know you guys
could just make up lyrics hangin round
downtown by myself and I had so much
time to sit and think about myself and
there she was yeah yeah and then there
she was like platform double suede then
she was like disco lemonade is sex and
candy ah yeah I totally knew that
thank you yeah you totally knew it okay
any other day I would call you and you
would say baby how's your day but today
it ain't the same is it just my memory
that's bad or do I just like not
prioritize lyrics enough i prioritize
much more important things like the
entire plots of movies yeah everything's
better at remembering movie plots were
like I I still don't know what happened
in any of the born identities I saw them
all I don't remember
ooh ooh Evans version of this game we
read movie synopsises and then we tried
to guess what movie that was oh yeah we
could try that you'd wait yes if you
can't win the game you're playing they
think of a new game and then you'll win
okay um do you want me to read it again
yes any other day I would have called or
I would call and you would say baby
how's your day but today it ain't the
same no are the female kini like in tune
any other day I would call you would say
dan dan the Van Deventer
baby has your day but today it ain't the
same every other word is a huh you okay
why don't just say the things they said
to me yesterday I get it now I don't
know who that is we got some people like
you don't even know the artist name do
you even stand
we must not be true Stanners no why
would so if if I was if I was calling my
significant other and I thought that
there was someone else there like
another girl there cheating yeah what
would I want him to say I'm sorry I
wouldn't have to say my name oh I'm
sorry works here right I think this is a
good place to end the lyrics game thanks
for indulging us alright guys well that
was really fun it was so interesting
trying to do this live I think that like
it's so interesting in general this
podcast kind of came together a little
bit last minute yeah we didn't have the
doing a game it was gonna be Q&A we
didn't think of it till like five
minutes before we went live yeah we just
kind of like you know flew by the seat
of our pants for this bond but I think
that this this podcast did go really
well enough that I really did have a fun
time I think that we should do this
again live every now and then maybe only
Q&A cuny might be a little easier
because we're really badly
yeah it's really hard to like we could
have more prepared things we could do
more poppy we didn't maybe coordinate
with the mods or like figure out like
some website to help yes coordinate and
facilitate this like I'm not sure how
elaborate we want to go with this but
this has been fun and we are going to do
this again yeah super fun can we do our
thing of the week's real quick wrap up
the virtual podcast do thing of the week
[Music]
okay so can see my thing of the week is
the elgato stream deck not sponsored but
I do really really like it we're using
it to run so much of our streaming setup
right now I think you like it like 10
times more oh when she found out that we
could do sound bites I also like it so
much more now that I can do folders and
folders and folders and bytes but also
like being able to manage the scenes
being able to record at the top push of
a button being able to like raid being
able to change them like all these modes
I am falling down the rabbit hole a
little bit and I've said that before in
previous streams but it is it's a very
valuable tool if you do live streams I
know that this is speaking to a very
small quantity of you guys but it's my
obsession and I just have to be honest
about gotta be your thing it's got to be
my thing yeah my thing of the week is
another podcast it's the philip defranco
podcast which is called a conversation
with and there's not a are you about to
do a I was like pause there's not a ton
of episodes yet but they're they've been
super interesting so far I really like
philip defranco and it's cool to hear
him just speak more like casually yeah
I've got the feeling like he actually
doesn't yeah speak in jump-cuts in real
life yeah I've got the feeling that like
he he's still like Philip DeFranco for
show but like he's admitted that at some
point he wants to kind of like step away
from that at some point and I get the
feeling he really enjoys the podcast he
really enjoys the podcast I think that
like when you're watching someone that
really enjoys what they're doing
it really makes the end product a lot
better so it's yeah so it's super
interesting I mean I just I've only
listened to a few I mean there's not a
ton yeah I listen to like the Casey and
I said interview the Casey nights out in
the Neary was very interesting because I
did like I kind of knew that Casey had
stepped back from YouTube a little bit
but he's like really stepped back and
it's really behind yeah cuz also it's
like Casey talks about how he got so
obsessed so like caught up in in YouTube
and like vlogging in particular every
moment in his personal and work life
he's like how can I turn this into a
vlog how can I turn this into a moment
how do I like create content from this
and that kind of like changed how he
thinks about his life and all of these
moments and stuff and I think that we've
definitely been able to stay away from
that because we plan and coordinate and
we keep like a slower schedule with
release and everything and also like
we're not I think it's different it's
not about her life yes yeah our videos
aren't about our life so it's not like
oh we're doing a thing we have to
capture it pressure but they also talked
about like the future of content what
they think you know it's gonna be you
know hot things in the future and
everything is things or something it's
just really interesting yeah but there's
a bunch of a bunch of good ones but yeah
that's my thing of the week
and then I think that might be the end
of the show thank you guys so much for
joining us today if you guys like the
podcast make sure to subscribe and I
think that one thing that really helped
us reach a broader audience is if you
shared it with someone so send this to
someone and we'll look forward to seeing
you for the next episode look at you
with your your outro music
see you next time
hi everyone but anyone who's live stick
around cuz was awesome way